foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's back
wait bring up that tweet that I linked
getting nailed for the camera is back
what's this guy's name he's really funny
he said only fan CEO staring at a
picture of naked Marge Simpson oh my god
I've made a mistake we need to allow
pornography on the site assistant but
sir we just CEO frothing at the mouth do
it do it now it's not as funny when you
read it out you know so the thing is
they so like I don't know why they made
crazy big this is like press release
that they're banning porn and not like
explaining what it is they're banning
well you know why they did that why well
people would be pissed and click and
that's it you think so yes we did it on
purpose they made it ambiguous on
purpose no all the all the reporting
like the news sites did yeah they want
to get arguing okay that's true deep
[ __ ] philosophical take here arguing
is the new porn
okay this is not it's not a very astute
observation but right they're just
pissing people off is a new porn like
it's getting people to argue and getting
them angry yeah you can do that [ __ ] all
day and yeah news news sites are the
[ __ ] worst when it comes to that [ __ ]
yeah they're the most click-baiting
people ever yeah they
all that [ __ ] is evil like that like
Banning porn it's like
okay they did ban pornographic media in
that sex on camera was like no more and
maybe that included like video in
general of like I don't know squirting
yeah but porn is a catch-all term in
most cases for softcore porn too which
is what only fans is yeah mostly yeah
but you can still post naked pictures
that's what I'm saying but these
headlines make it seem like you can't
anymore yeah people went [ __ ] crazy
and they were like What's it gonna be
now yeah it's like it's gonna still be
exactly what it is it's just they're
banning like the five percent of like
dildo videos which is still a big deal
but it's not as big of a deal as
everyone made it seem to be yeah and
then that's why all the jokes about it
to me felt sort of lazy because I'm like
if they're still porn yeah there's
definitely still porn and then you know
they took it back so
uh
we did it internet
what was crazy is that
so they did it to appease their like
payment
companies yeah payments uh platforms
basically we're like hey we we don't
support this anymore because you know
pornographic content there's no way to
like verify that miners aren't in it and
all this stuff yeah and then these guys
need money too and they're having hard
hard time raising money yeah even though
their revenue their net revenue last
year was I think five billion dollars or
something that's crazy something like
that yeah
um but they're trying to raise money to
I'm assuming higher and grow faster yeah
um and they can't really because people
are like you're porn yeah it's the same
reason why Tumblr I think turned it off
and then eight years later went back I
think Tumblr was worth two billion
dollars or 8 billion or something like
that and then five years later
they sold it for three million dollars
and I'm not saying it's only the Banning
of porn that
led to that because Tumblr obviously was
like kind of a I don't know it's just a
social media platform they all die
eventually yeah but still it's like only
fans is only sexual content that's I
mean that's the main premise like I get
that they're trying not to be that but
that's what they are man it's Gotta Own
It 11 billion dollars it was worth 1.1
billion 1.1 billion that's what sold for
a couple that's what Yahoo bought it for
three yeah three million
oh boy what a fall from grace
so an interesting thing is that only
fans is trying to move more towards
uh safe for work content yeah so they
came out with this app it's a safer work
app called oftv
and I downloaded it just to see what it
was yeah it is just trash
[Laughter]
it's unreal it looks like they put two
Junior iOS Engineers on it and they were
like all right make make do something
what what was the YouTube the super
small YouTube competitor for a long time
vid me vid me yeah yeah no and that was
like a kind of a slick app honestly no
that was a great app but whenever you
went on there there wasn't a ton of
great content yes that's all like that's
the hardest part now about creating us
anything that's
you know supposed to offer media
it's so hard to compete because to get
quality like content on there unless
it's like [ __ ] jam-packed with [ __ ]
it's just it looks like ass yep it makes
such a bad impression what what's what
uh what is the premise of this series
I'd love to know what MIA Khalifa
unlocked stands for says Mia Khalifa
hits the streets for an all-day
Adventure in the season 2 premiere of
unlocked Mia and host Casey Boonstra
turn themselves into 3D Holograms and
rock out in a classic dot dot dot who
cares yeah it's a vlog yeah click on it
foreign
[Music]
okay I'm thinking it's in
um oh my gosh there's it's more like
what can so you know what this is go 90.
yeah yeah this is full screen yeah
yeah
that you know I was actually thinking
about this the other day
where
there seems to be this disconnect
with when like when creating these
platforms that
uh like the money people think
just by virtue of inserting a talent
into content that automatically makes it
interesting yeah but it's like no
anyone can do this for the most part
like there's nothing inherently
interesting about two people going in
putting on mocap suits and then getting
3D versions of themselves to like 100
who gives a [ __ ] there's nothing
compelling there yeah here's the thing
if this was on YouTube probably wouldn't
have that crazy number of views no so
it's like why would people actually this
website is free right like we just
watched that yeah yeah yeah yeah I think
the idea is that they're trying to
become sort of like a premium that's why
it's all called unlocked because it's
like this is a free version I'm pretty
sure yeah and then there'll be a paid
version
so it's like they're kind of trying to
become like patreon a little bit yeah
but who [ __ ] cares
which is like a mean thing to say but
it's it's just
oh man it gets on my nerves because the
stuff that's compelling is either
someone
putting forward like they they put
themselves like their reputation out and
then they're like I'm I'm gonna
you know I'm gonna say these things and
then I'm gonna put this like this is my
bet and I'm this is what I'm risking
it's like I'm risking me and people
enjoy that like that to me is like
stand-up comedy right and then anything
outside of that like it's just a good
story
you want like that's kind of what you're
looking for in content I feel yeah and
this like full screen go 90 media has
always driven me crazy because you could
tell it's just money people
who don't get media and but somehow
they're the guys at the front that are
like oh man we're doing this great
series with Mia Khalifa she's doing all
kinds of cool stuff yeah she gets an
emotion capture suit and she rocks out
in front of a crowd it's like no no one
ever asked for that and here's the thing
well here's the thing is that yeah yeah
I'll do no one asked for that
we still [ __ ] do it yeah no but
here's the thing is that
um
that that series might be good who knows
we didn't watch many much better it
might be good you know yeah but with
YouTube you have the recommendation
algorithm built in it's like it's built
to expose content like yes it is so hard
to convert someone off Instagram who is
used to seeing pictures of you or only
fans where they're used to seeing
pictures of you to now watch a vlog a 20
minute Vlog of you doing something that
they don't really relate to right yeah
it's really hard to convert that yeah
the thing is like with us the reason why
patreon works is because we have made so
many episodes uh for free of us already
doing this yeah that it's like people
are willing to pay for another episode
because they're used to us in this style
and they like watching us in this style
yeah but to go from hey I am posted I
only post Instagram pictures to then
being like I'm in this 20 minute premium
series on this website that you've never
heard of it's such a hard jump to make
it's so huge
and also you chose the most boring thing
that they could do putting on green
suits and then getting mocap like VFX is
probably on the top 20 most
uninteresting things to the general
public this is kind of cool to me
yeah that's because we're [ __ ] nerds
like so what do they do with them that's
literally what everyone would ask in the
first 30 seconds of this like look what
what's the timestamp on that 13 minutes
yep I you know call it 10 before they're
actually into the software like this is
all anyone wants to see
like what happens after well you know
what's crazy is that they're also
getting paid
like Mia Khalifa whoever that other girl
is they're getting paid a lot for this
oh yeah
because you know only fans right now is
in that period where they're like we
gotta move to family friendly which
means we've got to spend a big bag on
people that are already big on our
platform to do [ __ ] that's not post
naked people yes yep